and creamed corn yeah
let's read this pissing lady apology i
gotta see this we talked about last
about this last week that was uh sophia
urista
piss on the guy's face on stage and i
guess now she apologized
she got cancelled for p
come on man
let's just pee
what does it say here hey everyone i
want to speak to my performance
at rockville metal festival in in
daytona daytona florida
dang if there was ever a place to pee on
someone's face it's [ __ ] daytime
obviously isn't that just normal there
yeah i have always pushed the limits in
music and on stage that night i pushed
the limits too far sophia no you didn't
i love my family
[Music]
the band
[Music]
and the fans
more than anything and i know that
some were hurt or offended by what i did
i apologize to them and want them to
know that i didn't mean to hurt them so
i can't really read this i'm not a shock
artist
[Music]
i'm not a shock artist i always want to
put music put the music first
i'm grateful for all of the continued
love and support
[Music]
lastly lastly i do want to say if you're
into this sort of stuff i would check
out the perverse family oh that's weird
[Laughter]
i featured in many perverse family
projects
and i'm a big fan of what they do
when i'm not on stage i do love to push
p out of my body
i
dude so i learned that they're a cover
band and i think they were covering rage
that night they're doing a rage against
machine song
so she you know is
feeling anarchist [ __ ] is that is
that something that rage did did they no
but i think you know maybe she just like
if there's some sort of like thematic
connection then i guess i would
understand it but if it was something it
was something that she just did
completely randomly like
if that if if instead she took like the
sheriff who was maybe overseeing the
crowd yeah exactly it was like get up
here yeah and urinated on then maybe
yeah you know that would be rage ish
yeah you know like [ __ ] the system kind
of thing but
yeah
i don't think she pushed it too far i
think everyone's being sensitive
i thought it was weird as [ __ ]
i mean it's weird but
also also like did she tell the guy i
wonder
but like what she was gonna do maybe
that part because like there's probably
a moment there where he was like she's
she might sit on my face
she might [ __ ] on my face
what's gonna happen here he's hoping for
both
the the he walked outside there's a
moment where he's just staring straight
up but you know yeah at her cornhole
yeah
getting dumped on man cornhole and her
b-hole yeah
i think those are synonymous
no i said cornhole in her p hole okay
not b-hole
you can't really see cornhole or b-hole
yeah staring up at the
chocolate starfish
you know it's just like looking into the
jets of a hot tub a really nice hot tub
it's just four or five
holes that are gonna spray
how many holes do women have you know
yeah who knows no one really knows
they're like they're like a you know
like a ocarina from zelda you know
it's just like a series of you know
yeah yeah yeah what's that what's that
like it looks like an iphone looks like
this
yeah the iphone camera yeah
if you yes
dude what's that like phobia that people
have yeah yeah this [ __ ] tripped
a phobia yeah they see a bunch of holes
that's pretty common yeah don't eat
[ __ ] you hook up with women yeah
don't eat [ __ ] you'll be very scared of
how many holes are down there
it's way more than you think don't lift
her legs up it'll freak you out
seeing more than one hole so that guy
was probably just like paralyzed with
fear at that moment on stage he's like i
have tripped
i've tripped
that [ __ ] went to the dentist
dude [ __ ] clean your [ __ ] out and
just
dude man and like you know
like when women pee it's it's not like
male p you know it doesn't it's not like
because it comes out of six different
holes yeah yeah
it's kind of like they pee like when a
like a catholic priest like dips the
leaves into like holy water and like you
know reigns it on the audience you ever
experienced that yeah
i mean not really but you don't see that
in a catholic church like they dip a
bunch of leaves and he just like throws
it on the crowd
[Music]
oh
it's like that like like when women pee
it's like
like it's uh kind of random yeah yeah
yeah or like emptying out like a
gasoline canister just yeah it's
see he was getting hit
and and who knows like what he thought
like
you know he just opened his mouth he's
like let's go but then it's like
you know let's go forehead eyes like
probably when his nostril you know what
i'm saying like just he got hit you know
but he wanted that i think that's i
think where i was going with that is i
think he wanted that experience they
probably should have talked about it
beforehand because if he didn't and she
pulled down her pants over his eyes he
would have rolled out of there yeah yeah
he had a moment to be like what the [ __ ]
no but you're on stage
in front of people it's like that'd be
embarrassing people would be like
you know what i mean
yeah like once he was up there he's like
i'm committing to whatever is happening
peer pressure is real yeah if you if you
were up there do you think you would
have rolled out the way yeah
yep
yes
i think confidently i would have
i think so too yeah if i saw a butthole
over my eye
i'm out i would have stood up and
screamed what are we doing
what the [ __ ] what are we doing here but
you were i thought you were gonna have
me like sing part of the song
give me a like a microphone or so what
the [ __ ] is this i would have actually
yeah i would have treated that no your
butthole i would have treated that like
um
getting rear-ended and rolling out of
the car and being like i can't see
i would have milked that i would have
stood up and been like [ __ ] in my eyes
she [ __ ] in my eyes
i would have let it happen
so that afterwards you could
sue no i i would have like you know you
know something i would have tried to
finesse something
because it's such a unique moment for an
insurance claim yeah yeah
so funny to take that case to court
and be like i didn't know i didn't
wanted to get pee on my face the judge
was like what what did you think was
gonna happen yeah when you saw when you
saw the butthole
at that moment what did you think was
gonna happen your honor shut the [ __ ] up
i'm asking the defendant i'm asking the
plaintiff
what did you think was gonna happen
what comes out of buttholes poop exactly
case dismissed honestly you got lucky
yeah yeah lucky it wasn't poop
now when she i can't even do her voice
judge judy i can't do it either were you
talking to her before yeah whatever this
is like some jersey yeah like some [ __ ]
here's my judge judy impression
when she put a butthole over your
[ __ ] face what do you think was gonna
happen you think was gonna happen huh
what the [ __ ] comes out of a butthole my
guy poop on